hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the European women's
rapid championship its former world's
women champion na na garden - village is
the sixth women's world champion versus
Amaya to Britain it's a who is the
seventh world women's chess champion and
gaprindashvili has been world champion
for 16 years before facing myotube units
in 1978 so over 40 years have passed
since the two of them played their match
for the World Chess Championship 40 41
years I believe so it's incredible that
they are still very active and still
playing competitive chess if you well
Maha is 58 years old and Nonna is 78
years old so when some of you say that
you you know you're like 50 and you are
too old for chess you can always look at
no leg up in the field who's not only
playing competitive chess she's playing
the world rapid champion the European
rabbit championship so that's really
incredible and one of the reasons why I
decided to show this game as they are
both a Legends when it comes to chess
it's like I said from the European
rabbit championship and it was held in
Monte Carlo and it was also the first
edition of the your Europe's golden pawn
Awards now if you're wondering what the
you Europe's golden pawn awards is I'm
wondering as well so you have to google
it and from there what appears to be the
official website it says Europe's golden
pawn is a new tradition and brings
together the best representatives of the
European chess world Itchy each year
chess stands for people of intelligence
brilliant and flexible minds and we
always stay where there are healthy
highly intellectual and interesting
activities and ideas so that's basically
the Europe's Golden Pond and there will
be awards like for Best author for best
best arbiter for I've seen there are
awards for woman's chest legend men's
just legend there are well a lot of
award you can win every year so that
being said we do have some photos from
the event here they are
there we have it that's you this polgár
alongside honor oodles and hooga hooga
sent me these photos so thanks for that
now you did probably will be receiving
the
the chess Legend Award I imagine and
also here is one with Garry Kasparov and
there you have it he will probably be
receiving the the other chest Legend
Award maybe not I still haven't checked
it out so if you any of you do not do
sure in the comment section below and
the Garry Kasparov also held us I mean
simultaneous exhibition there if you any
of you attend it and you have a nice
game that you would like to show maybe
someone you know played against Gary and
it was a nice game do send it I will
definitely check it out and show it and
here we have also a nice photo of the
two of them playing there we have it on
board thirteen Nona versus Maya there we
have it both of them deep in the
position and there they're behind hygge
you can see a wild Orca did work which
appears the the field president is also
enjoying the match between these two
legends so that being said let's check
out the game no not with the white
pieces opens with d4 with East six c4
and d5 with Knight to f3 and now c6 the
slot defense is on the board we have
Queen to c2 and Knight to d7 now Bishop
to f4 and here comes Knight G to f6 so
just nicely developing a Knight bTW -
and Bishop to e7 Maya prepares the
castle with h3 and now castles by Maya
with III and now the early c5 as the
White King is still in the center of the
board of course you want to open up the
position and here there is a game that
continued C captures and e5 but b3 is a
new move in the position so already as
of move nine we have a completely new
game with b6 Maya will finger to the
light square Bishop as well we have
Bishop to d3 putting pressure on the h7
pawn for the moment it's not a problem
since the Knight is guarding at Bishop
to be seven and now castles we have
looked the c8 and now comes Luke 8 a d1
nicely aligning the rook along the D
file if the position opens up that's
where you want to have your rope we have
rook to e8 and now Queen back the b1 not
wanting the Queen on the same file as
this rook Knights the f8 now the night
is coming to g6 and from there the night
we'll be a very useful piece so we have
D captures in c5 and here Bishop
captures on c5 and finally if for a
breakthrough in the center we have D
captures on e4 and now Knight captures
on e4 the night is protected would
attacked it even though it's attacked
twice since the rook is still on the
same file as the Queen so we do have one
trade Bishop characters on e4 Knight
captures on e4 also possible as the the
bishop is a very strong piece but Maya
prefers Bishop captures on e4 with
Bishop captures now opening up an attack
towards the Queen and the Queen to e7
now and Bishop the back to c2 not
allowing the straight and for the moment
Nona has the advantage of the bishop
repair so if it's a well correctly
utilized it will be a deadly bishop pair
for example there should be two the c3
will be well an excellent bishop pair so
nice the g6 attacking the bishop bishop
back to d2 now with the idea of bringing
bringing it to c3 and then the bishop
repair will be fully operational with
rook d8 as the rope is no longer useful
on EI tend the bishop to c3 now now the
bishops are definitely fully operational
with a 5 I just further improving the
position on the Queen side if you look
at it and if you take away you know if
you imagine all the pieces of the board
White has a three-to-two advantage on
the Queen side so that's always better
than having an advantage on the King
side where the Kings are since the the
King will be able to compensate for the
hour for one last point or one last poem
so 3 to 2 on the Queen side the
definitely a plus if you can trade down
into that endgame we have Queen to c1
not allowing Knights to f4 also the
Queen also wants to enter the game
somehow and night the h5 now now this
night is coming to f4 and unless you
want to ruin your pawn structure a bit
well g3 would be a blunder here because
you can just capture the F pawn is
pinned but there's really no good way to
prevent it so we have rook cap 478
Trading a pair of rooks rook after sandy
8 and now rook to d1 offering a trade
off of another rook we have Knight H 2 F
4 now finally grabbing that nice
Foursquare and here rook captures on da
trading the other pair of rooks as well
Queen captures on dat and now Queen to
d1 offering a trade of Queens as well as
Nona figures the the end game will be
Advent advantageous to her since the
bishop pair is still on the board with
Queen captures on d1 Maya disagrees with
this and Bishop captures on d1 with
Knight the d3 now putting pressure on
the F to pawn and now you don't really
have a good way of defending the the
points so you have to you know put put a
bishop in in between so rush up to d4
and now if I'm not wanting to trade on
the force of the night gets activated
immediately but rather be five and now
you force white to capture on c5 so
Bishop captures on c5 and now not Knight
captures but B captures and here you
have perfect control of the be for
square so even though White has a
three-to-two advantage and the Queen
side you will not be pushing a 3 and B 4
maybe you will if all the pieces maybe
get traded off and the black king will
be far away so maybe you can sacrifice a
pawn to start marching your c5 pawn C
pawn but other than that very unlikely
so Bishop / c2 attacking the knight and
now Knight G to F for here my eyes
offering a trick for example if you try
to kick the night away with the g3 it
does remove the defender of this night
but it doesn't work simply Knight
captures on h3 comes with check and now
after King f1 you're going to capture on
f2 as well and after King to e2 now
again threatening to win the peace now
efore Knight to g5 and then now after
let's say h6 you will simply pick up the
four pawn Knight captures on e4 and
Bishop captures on d3
but Knight captures on g3 with check and
after all is said and done white will
dwell black will enjoy two extra points
and it will be it will be an easy win
for black so after Knight G to F 4 we
have King to F 1 now g3 definitely a
threat but black no longer waits for for
g3 so night the B for putting pressure
on the bishop and the pawn here Bishop
the b1 and now f6 just strengthening the
e5 pawn with a3 pushing the knight back
and the not knight back to see
it's now the night will harass the b3
pond from d4 so you can white is still
okay here but you can feel that it's
black was dictating the tone of the
battle and even though Nona had the
bishop pair maybe trading the training
drugs was great but trading the Queen
may be the Queen's should have remained
on the board a bit longer but you know
things happen in chess with Knights to
d2 now adding a defender to the b3 pawn
as you are expecting night to d4 with
Knights to d4 and now Bishop to c4
getting the bishop into the game and
here comes King to f7 now Maya starts
improving the position of the king with
h4 now you can push g3 without H h3
being a target and now f5 pushing the
bishop further back push it back to be
one and now comes King to f6 and here f3
we have night after night after Ito just
a very nice night as well if the night
comes to c1 there's a really no way for
you to defend b3 reason being that well
Bishop the c2 is not possible the night
covers that Square and if Bishop to a2
nice to see one just traps it and then
you're just gonna lose it well you don't
lose a piece you can retreat to be one
but then you lose the b3 point either
way so it's a very hard for white to
make a move here here Nona tries g4 but
we have just g6 and here it's like I
said it's incredibly hard to find a move
for white if you try it something like
Bishop to d3 trying to win a piece or
something just nice to see one and you
will lose the b3 pawn there's no way
around that there's no defending the
point if you try something like Bishop
to a2 we already mentioned nice to see
one just attacks the bishop alongside
upon you you're gonna have to move the
bishop back and then you just lose the
pawn or if after Bishop to Knight c3 you
go Bishop back to be one you can just
capture it and after Knight captures you
will then capture on b3 so it's playing
something like a 4-2 to waste time just
Knight see one again loses the b3 pawn
then again why falls apart it's a very
important point
so here
no not tried a very well the only active
idea basically in the position age five
point is that now Maya place Knights to
c1 yes the b3 pony you cannot save it
but what you can do is exactly what Nona
did H capture sin g 6h captures g
captures on f5g captures on f5 and now B
for something we mentioned that if the
maybe maybe if the pieces were all
traded and if the black King was very
far away then maybe you could sacrifice
a pawn on the Queen side to create a
path C pawn but now it's made out of
necessity as there there was no way to
defend the b3 point so C capture son
before we have eight captures captures
and now c5 starting to put the passport
although it's not really all that much
of a problem for black since the black
king is very close we have King to e6
and the now King to e one night c2e2
and Bishop to d3 now threatening to win
a piece Knight back to c3 and now Bishop
to c4 with check King to b7 and now King
to f2 the the nights are really making
it hard for the White King to reach
anything here we have King to c6 now the
phone is threatened that there's no way
to defend it might be three but black
just straight and then picks up the pawn
so here we have King to e3 but now King
captures on c5 and here black is just up
two points so definitely a decisive
advantage and here we have f4 by Nona
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute best way for
Maya to win this position with black
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the absolute
best way to win it it's it's a force
mate in 12 if if black if white this
defense properly so it's nice to d1
congratulations to everyone who found
that this comes with check the black
King has nowhere to go
we have King to d3 and now you can see
that the Knights control all of the
squares around the White King so all
that's left is to push efore efore with
check and now the White King has no more
squares you're gonna have to give up
start giving up material and it was of
course in this position
that nona gaprindashvili resigned the
game I'll move 51 as there is nothing
more to be done here you will give up a
piece here for example after captures
with check-in captures you're then gonna
lose the bishop and even though you have
a one more pawn it's not really gonna be
a problem black and you can just capture
it you know for good measure and after
this you will just continue to push your
beep on and Queen it and win the game so
there are no tricks in the position of
course Nonna decided to resign after
this
efore check move so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it really an awesome
and a very inspiring game to see the two
of them still going at it after for 41
years after their World Chess
Championship match in 1978 really very
motivational so III do hope you enjoyed
it that's the game I would also like to
thank Dawg McNabb Gabi austenite and the
Jeff graves for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
continue to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world and also for those who
maybe don't know the Vladimir Kramnik
who retired from professional chess is
coming back from retirement to play the
world rapid and blitz championship from
25 to 30 of of December this year so
there's that so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day